hey what's up my name's Samuel Leeds and
this one is Wednesday is one of the most
exciting windows Wednesdays we ever had
and not only this guy I'm about to
introduce you to he joined the Academy
last year in April made this investment
back did some cool things in property
but he's gone on to revolutionize the
way that property investing is done here
in the UK through an app which is
absolutely blowing up at the moment I
did a video about this on Monday it's
now Wednesday tomorrow's gonna be
traveling the world going all around
Italy and everywhere so I thought before
we start travelling around the world
with his amazing app and financial
freedom of success we needed to get into
my house to share the story and also get
you guys in on what's going on so Ashley
welcome to my home buddy thanks so much
for being here thank you for having me
I'm so happy to be here you've even a
crazy twelve months yeah it's been
really crazy time
yeah joined the Academy in April by kind
of mid-july made the money back through
through this platform we're talking
about today deal source us when did you
first come up with this idea so I had I
had the idea when I came across your
stuff in maybe 2018 yeah I had the idea
but then I was like yeah whatever and
then I joined the Academy in in April
and I came to the DfE and was like okay
this is really about seeing as many
properties as possible yeah thus you
need to filter through a lot of
properties on Rightmove but so much of
it was repetitive I was like could I
build I'd literally built it for myself
I didn't build it for anyone else I
built it for myself
fix my own problem and then I had a few
people say well that's a bit insane can
I use that and I was like yeah I guess
and I gave it to them and then within a
matter of weeks we had hundreds of
people using our I I was what's going on
and then people like you really need to
start charging for this yeah you turn
and the rest is history
but what was happening within the
Academy was there's always teaching
strategies how to find properties how to
and everyone was saying to me oh yeah we
just used the app you know we just used
the app and I'm thinking okay that's
kind of like that's kind of making voice
part of my teaching
something like this Ashley dude I need
to kick this guy off of the Academy or
something I'm just kidding but you know
so I'm kind of hearing about it
and I know we knew each other through
the Academy loosely we'd met and stuff
yeah and you did things in property you
had some rent to rent and you seemed
like you know a happy happy student but
this this app kept coming up and
everyone was talking about this app and
I'm not a super techy guy I'm kind of
old school so you had a bit of
opposition from me in the early days
tell me about that yeah I mean yeah it
kind of did a lot of a lot of the things
you were teaching it automated but my
view was that once we got the product to
a really good point and we brought it
back to you you'd actually see okay if I
give this to my students and everyone
else they're gonna do more deals they're
gonna make more money
it's gonna be beneficial to everyone
else so yeah it was uh III had the faith
faith did you join the Academy to do the
app no no no no no a hundred percent no
like I had a tech business before this
and it was a really hard process like
four years of pain yeah and I was like
I'm never doing tech again I'm going
into property I'm selling my stake in my
business and I'm just gonna do HMOs and
single oats and then I did the DfE and
as I've mentioned I gave it I gave the
app to a few people when it blew up and
then I was like maybe I kind of overlap
these two things yeah so I'll finish the
Academy and I'll keep looking at deals
and trying to buy things myself and then
the app just kind of took over it took
over all my time because I realized that
if you do this properly you fix all
these problems that people commonly have
so then they're spending their time only
go into the properties that only makes
sense
in the right areas yes so it was it was
obvious from the feedback I was getting
from people they were like basically
after they use that they couldn't
imagine not using it so that's the same
with me because it's like having the
iPhone and having the knock yeah yeah so
and I want to get into the app shortly
and all the features of it and how that
came about and how you did it but the
cool thing is is you've actually done it
as a property investor yes you you've
gone through the process you've had
you've had rent to rent you you've sold
property
deels you've made money in property
which is which is cool so so you're not
someone that's come at a techie person
that's tried to something for property
investors you genuinely have found a
problem
I fixed it for myself first you know I
did I did it for me like the app
originally wasn't an app it was it was
it was an ugly little thing that just
found me loads of deals and then I
showed it to people and then I turned it
into a product so yeah a hundred percent
it was for me it wasn't for anyone else
let's talk to those people that maybe
didn't see my Monday video and if he
didn't if you watching this now and you
didn't watch my video on Monday which
was a couple days ago I suggest checking
it out but let's talk to you what the
app actually does so firstly it finds
potential hexamers yep so talk to me
about that how does it do that so the
whole app works on the same basis that
normal people do it basically goes onto
all the websites for you and finds all
the properties and then figures out and
what websites does it go on Rightmove
Zoopla all of these okay so it basically
does what you do it looks a deal and
says with this work as a single with
this workers at HMO with this is this a
BRR deal is this and it figures out the
right deal type for the property and
then does all the numbers so for an HMO
it figures out the average room rent in
the area uses the spare room local
information and calculates what it is
for an HMO which you know obviously
you've explained basically let's say I
want to find a HMO in Birmingham rather
than me having to look through all of
the properties and then find the
potential HMOs all the existing HMOs and
then work out how much rent I'd get and
go on the different comparable slots
then go into the salmon Zoopla it just
brings it all together it's already done
oh the numbers are really done so you
literally type Birmingham tap HMO and
then just now this is why it's
disruptive okay to the industry because
a deal saucer a big part of what ideal
saucer will do in the apps I'm a cold
deal sorcerer is they will identify
potential properties now of course
there's more to it you got a review it
negotiate it but a lot of the work the
deal sources doing that people paid the
others to do is what the app does yes
the legwork so how do you feel or how do
you think you might already know the
answer deal sources are going to react
to this are they going to be kicked off
are they gonna be like yo you've
suddenly made
don't think I'm charging a couple
thousand pounds for of course it's a bit
more to than that but you've suddenly
made it completely available so that the
the average person who doesn't
necessarily you can just boo find these
deals it calculates the return on
investment before you so do you think
deal sources are going to be ticked off
or a deal source is going to be pleased
because it will actually save them time
what's the response the response is 95%
positive there's like I'd say it's about
5% of people that say all this
competitive to what I do and things like
that but the majority of people know
because it's obvious because actually I
remember chatting with James Armstrong
wrote back early on when I was building
it and he said look if I sell a deal for
3k and I spend X my hours on it if your
app reduces the amount of hours then how
much I make per hour goes up so I make
more money so why would I not use it I
guess the reason that people might be
upset a deal sorcerer would be that they
like the fact that they have to put a
lot of hours in it because they can
justify to their client I spent six
hours finding this property when they
know when everyone knows because this is
going to become a household name I've no
doubt certainly in the investment space
when everybody knows actually the app
does it instantly it kind of takes away
from the research that needs to go into
it and I think that's potentially quite
some deals also might be ticked off but
maybe I'm wrong no I think I think
you're right I just think that you know
how hard it is to get great deals like a
lot of it is the negotiation and going
to view the properties and just you know
deals don't stack or there's an issue
with subsidence all this it's a numbers
game you've got a view a lot of property
like you always said the person who've
used the most property that the person
who makes the most money yeah so why not
cut out all that other time you spend
doing the analysis and go out there and
view all the properties negotiate the
deal so frankly speaking like a deal
sorcerer is going to make ten times the
amount of money they could possibly make
using a product that takes away all of
the time they've spent analyzing deals
and spreadsheets so it's it's innovation
right innovation this what innovation
does it opens people up to do other
things that are better that are more
valuable that are more productive
you what about horses and cars and
people say that like okay so what you
prefer to still have horse now you can
do more things now carro that do what
that's kind of what one wouldn't yet
that's what innovations like it's like
this I was honestly and I've said this
before I was honestly somewhat
threatened by the app yeah because I'm
like I'm like wow this app is gonna
suddenly make and here's the really I
want to think my whole messages
everything I do is about making property
investment accessible for everybody yes
right I teach people a powerfully
content but certainly when this ad came
out there was a part of me that was like
is this gonna he's just gonna make what
I do redundant a little bit he's just
gonna
it was so disruptive and honestly if you
see the app I mean I'd recommend by the
way how much how much does that cost its
forty five pounds a month yeah but if
they use your link they get a lot
cheaper is like all right cool yeah
and by the way disclaimer I'm one can
talk about the conversation I have
shares in the app yeah well I says just
a disclaimer and I I don't speak well of
the app because I have shares in it I
have shares in it because I was afraid
not to because I knew how big it was
gonna go and I'm like damn I gotta get
involved somehow so we worked that deal
but like it's by the way thank you very
much
we're really really happy no thanks
because it was gonna be big with or
without me I'm glad to be part of it but
I think what kind of changed my way of
thinking was I thought number one is
it's gonna help with my mission of
making property investing easy and
accessible for as many people as
possible
number two is exactly what you just said
when there's an advancement people
always get kicked off when there's an
advancement you know like when people
say oh well now you can go to a shop and
you can buy stuff without ever speaking
to a person that's gonna make people
redundant and then they get annoyed
because of the advancement or cars what
about the horses people always get when
the internet first came that we were
discussing this earlier absolutely you
know people were freaking out and they
were saying it was from the devil and it
was bad but actually when things when
advancements come out that make jet
daily life easier whether that be for
property investors or for anyone I think
it's always a good thing
it makes society better yeah we should
always be driving to do this all the
time
why there's that that's the definition
of a true entrepreneur I think I think a
true entrepreneur is somebody that
actually finds a problem solves the
problem and makes people's lives better
yeah ten times as long as the product is
ten times better
that's it yeah but that opens up for
more innovation other things like you
said you know people get to spend time
something they get to spend time on
things they love instead of sitting in a
spreadsheet calculating numbers and then
making mistakes that's the other thing
it stops people from making mistakes
like if it's very easy if you're sitting
in a spreadsheet constantly doing your
numbers like okay I forgot on this deal
that are okay I didn't put insurance
each month to take that out or I forgot
I don't know I used the wrong rate for
the agencies or are you all of that
stuff is just done for you yeah you just
look at the deals so does it mean that
because I teach people how to calculate
the ROI would you say that people don't
need to know how because it just does it
for you or do you not know no they still
need to know cuz they need to know what
we're doing what we're doing is we're
basically finding great investments
which basically means a high return on
capital right hook cash in and you get
the maximum out per annum so they still
need to know that I think you look at
how much people charge to find good
deals couple thousand pounds for one
good deal yeah your app is scraping the
whole Internet yep providing all of the
good deals just there to people yeah
185,000 of this morning so yeah and it's
45 pounds a month is that with or
without the discount code that's that's
without the disc without the discount
code so with the discount code I don't
know what it is even less yeah so you
know that's really insane talk to me a
little bit about the Academy because you
know I know you've done ridiculously
well with the app and also you've done
other property deals and stuff but talk
to me a bit about your whole experience
to the process so I I was I was in a I
started a tech business before this and
I was done with technology it was a very
hard
it was a very it was like Elon Musk
calls a chewing glass and staring into
the abyss like tech is hard it's not
what people think anyway I was in that
process and I was like right
of Technology I'm gonna go into property
I've actually found her on YouTube and I
decided to join the Academy I'd been to
the crash course and I joined last April
and how much she paid out what twelve
thousand twelve K yeah yeah and I I sold
my stake in my previous business in the
June so I left then and then by mid July
had made back basically all the money so
how long is that three months four
months four months yeah yes three four
yeah yeah yeah worked yeah and it was it
was very quick as well like I think in
if I think in a four week period I made
like a K or something I just I didn't
know what was going on I was yeah it was
it was amazing and then then I decided
okay I can't just this is the wrong
business model I need to charge people a
subscription yeah yeah so I changed a
subscription model and then you know
been financially free ever since then so
that's so cool and you're you got to
vent to rents in Sheffield yes which
which yeah I got to vent events in
Sheffield with my financial freedom
challenge yeah that's why I did it I
really so I basically watched the
financial freedom video that was the
previous Christmas yes and then I came
to the crash course in the January and
then then I joined in or the April and
yeah I was like I'm just gonna do what
Samuel did I came to DfE and yeah I was
viewing a lot of properties and I teamed
up with one of the guys in the Academy
tan shout-out to him because he
basically handled a lot of the deal and
a lot of the troubles we had with her
and stuff and also selling it so massive
thank you to him and yeah we III put up
all the furniture I put the things on
the wall yeah we've decorated the whole
place and yeah it was it was an
interesting experience I think we I
think I actually did that I did that
before the DfE do you know it's really
interesting though and I'll say this too
before people say to me what's the best
strategy what's the best what should I
do
I think you know what that answer is
different for every individual person
yes there's there's no
rent to rents the best strategy or deal
sourcing or BRR or in fact it might be
none of them it might be that you need
to create an app right you've got to use
your skills your entrepreneurial Flair
and then you've got to just bring that
out somehow and I think you're a really
good example of someone that's done that
because you've come through the Academy
you've learned all the different
strategies you've done some stuff you've
had some success but then you've
actually thought actually well he scaled
is in tech yes the overlap I did the
Academy and you know openly like the
credit goes to you and your team I
basically took everything the Academy or
I made it as much of it as possible and
gave it away to the masses yeah so
obviously they've got to negotiate the
deals and they go do all that you know
the hard work but like the leg work is
done it cuts out all that initial
process right
yeah just spend your time looking at the
deals that make sense yeah instead of
wasting time in the audience what would
be the biggest reason why cuz not my
system abit everybody watching this
should just go get the app right I'll
leave a link in the description when
they can where they can download it get
information on it with a discount code
as well also it's free for seven days
okay well well literally free yeah it's
it's a trial you get like you get yeah
yeah so what happens so you you sign up
for the free trial which I think
everybody should do yes give me an
honest shame and the shame would plug
right now right okay so follow it follow
the link in the description sign up you
put in your card details you don't get
charged anything it's the same as
Netflix you know you saw Netflix you get
30-day trial you put your card details
that's it and if you want to keep using
it then also they expect to say said
they do the free trial what happens
because when I looked at when you first
create it initially you said it wasn't
like sharp and fancy nice and
user-friendly now when you go on it
it's just I'm beautiful undeniable you
look at it and you just like holy moley
what do you say you see the Bri hate you
know that you put your little search bar
of the area you want to look and then
the houses gonna yeah every type of deal
type is on there basically every type of
deal taupe we've even got planning and
development and all these other stuff
that we don't even talk about this on
there as well so yeah you basically pick
the deals hope you pick the location
whether you want BMV Xaro is all the
mixture of the two yeah go and close
some deals I think we won and it works
out the ROI on every single house on
right moves basically yeah yeah it's
just this would be the ROI if you bought
this house
yeah and we're super conservative like
we get recently been getting feedback
from people people saying all your
numbers that are too low I bear to me
that way well like it's better to be
that way because then if it's a 20% and
it comes out as 24 wouldn't you be happy
I better know everything as well I
haven't recently a complaint that I
heard was that all in my area there's
not enough you're not giving me enough
deals but it's like listen that's
because there obviously isn't anything
there no this app is not going to create
deals and say that this is a good deal
when it's not it's gonna be conservative
it's gonna give you the best of what's
there you got to be patient
you've got to get the app you've got to
check it three times a day while you're
on the toilet yeah literally like a bit
chilly checking the app I'm on it all
the time now I'm just on it all the time
so what what's next tomorrow you're
traveling the world you're going to
Italy tomorrow yeah so do you think that
like financial freedom laptop lifestyle
as someone who's a great hard worker
like you are but also who's about to be
traveling the world with a laptop
lifestyle financially free how
attainable is that I think it depends
like how hard you're willing to work
yeah really look you put in like 100
hours a week
regular yeah for a year yeah so I knew
that this had to be right to do
something with you I had to be a great
product it had to be to a point where as
undeniable because then it could grow
really fast so we put in the work I'm
all keep working that hard it won't make
a difference but yeah I think it depends
how hard people willing to work it's the
same with everything you do right like
there's so many people I talk to and I
just think like people not willing to
work hard enough anymore you know like
you've really gotta put in the work so I
think it's totally achievable and if you
see someone travel in the world making
passive income with this really popular
app or properties or whatever that's not
happened by mistake no that's been a
deliberate planned well thought-out that
person's gonna have probably took the
training that person's gonna have been
searching on Rightmove making difficult
phone calls had to fall out with people
because their friends and family have
tried to protect them saying they're
working too hard and then after all that
hard work then you've got the result
right yeah exactly exactly and then it's
then it's considered like an overnight
success and these other things but it's
not they don't see the you know like I'm
sure the same with you like I dreamt of
being an entrepreneur when I was 17 I'm
now 33 I've built multiple businesses
before this but like it's a lot you know
you have to put in the work oh yeah what
you expect it's not gonna be given to
you and but I think if people want to do
something similar to me and maybe want
to get into the tech space and want to
blend these two things it's not as hard
as people think it is you know when I
was at school I was considered the dumb
one yeah you know now I'm building now
I'm working in technology so like it's
all achievable you've just gotta put in
the work it's really that simple
I just don't yeah I don't think people
want to they want they would they they
they not everyone wants to put in the
work that's required and not and not
everyone wants to pay for education like
you know we were talking about this
before what do you think about that I
think that's very misguided
I think that's being I forgot the term
but it's like they're trying to they're
being cheap they're trying to cut their
costs we're like you should be thinking
about the episode in the ROI so I made a
hundred percent ROI on the Academy in
four months so over a year what is that
that's like a four hundred percent ROI
like it's insane I yeah and not only
with the with the education but also
with the aspect of well for a start all
the people that became customers a lot
of them were on the academy oh yeah yeah
100%
like I
is there's a network effect of the
Academy but there is a real network
effect meaning like inside the network
this value because people get to yeah
second secondly I get people pitching me
every single day on ideas I get people
pitching me on app ideas probably every
week I've got this app I've got this
idea I've got this thing you know I've
come up with this initiative and I
physically cannot give the time of day
to all of these people whereas if I've
got someone on the Academy that says I
got an idea it's much more likely that
I'll be able to go okay let's have a
look at it so I don't think if you if
you haven't been on the Academy not only
would you have not probably come up with
the idea because you wouldn't have done
I felt the need for it number to have
the initial audience to become customers
and number three I don't think I would
have partnered with you if you went on
the Academy so it was you know people
saying oh it's too much of an investment
you're right it's an investment but and
you don't have to do it you can do the
free stuff but if you're really serious
and if you really want to get go go fast
and go far yeah it's just a no-brainer
yeah also I want to be around
like-minded people yeah like I really I
got the vibe when I came to the crash
course like I got that vibe I was like I
need to be closer to the fire I need to
be closer to people to think this way I
need to so to me it was like initially
started as that and then when this
actually like started to take off I just
knew I was like I'm gonna convince
Samuel to to partner with me on this
I've just got to make it great fun today
it took a couple of meetings it took a
long time it was hard to convince yes
and no no no you you you were you were
kind of you're fair I guess you were
like yeah we get it we get it from you
yeah you you were fair but it was I
learnt what I would say is through that
experience I learned a ton what what did
you learn I you know the KISS principle
keep things simple stupid yeah we should
have kept things simple yeah I think
when you pitch someone you need to give
them like the elevator pitch and nothing
else yeah I think keeping things simple
focus on win win I mean
these obvious these are obvious
principles but like you know when you're
passionate and you're working on
something you get talked about actually
because if someone's listening who might
have an idea or a concept because it's
the same if you're pitching someone to
do a joint venture if you're pitching
someone to invest in a business if
you're pitching someone to collaborate
with you on on an app or an idea or a
concept the whole idea of of pitching
people are joining forces talk to me a
bit about that process because I think
it's really it's a skill that's really
essential to all business piece
investors it's literally everything
yeah it's deals right that's all that's
all we do yeah we just do deals whether
it's one big business which is a deal or
it's many little deals so the first
thing is you've said is you've got to
make your you've got to make your
service or your product really freaking
good yeah Elon Musk approach is ten
times better than anything else yeah
that's really simple just make it ten
times better than everything yeah and
you did that so reliable you did that so
when you came to me we looked at the
product he was like yes the product is
great but for my point of view I'm like
it's great however how can i benefit
from this right now exactly exactly how
can you benefit and how can we benefit
together yeah I think that that's kind
of there's there's two sides there's the
value add so you've got a rad value yes
these are the obvious things but they're
so important you've got a really
bringing value to the table
pitching someone an idea is not value
ideas are cheap executions everything so
like I think I'd be more important like
say your let's keep it really simple
you're trying to do a JV on a property I
would go out and do a bunch of deals and
get a bunch of track record and make
that 10x you know compelling as hell and
you can pitch that to someone yes and
the same goes for the app go out and do
something you don't need anyone like
this stuff is so true and then what
happens is then what happens is people
start then chase enough to you right
it's about it's all value because all
value is that you've got to make
yourself as you always said you got to
make yourself valuable yeah cuz then
there is no Pig because the first thing
I said to you is how people are on this
exactly how many people are on this how
many people are using this how many
people aware of this because because I
get people pitching all the time with an
idea so when you first came to me with
an idea
I heard it going around a little bit it
was kind of an idea I wasn't interested
I was just like I stupid well it Ridge
'''l II was it was it was just a
negative equity screener that's all it
did yeah gave you addresses and you
could send and also the amount of people
that had come to move that idea yeah as
negative equity screeners and I'm just
like all right cool yeah whatever but
then when you take it from an idea to
Samuel keeps hearing about this from
everybody do you know about the story
about the DfE with Russell nah so
Russell was at DFA you know the thing
where you ask you want to go away and
get the deals and come back with that
number yeah tell me I dunno but tell me
right yeah yeah okay so Jules shout outs
Jules he he actually text me after this
so I knew about it and then Russell told
me so anyway they basically get everyone
to go and find a bunch of deals come
back and you compete for the numbers who
found the most deals in the hour and
it's like oh I found five and then this
table found 20 and you know I found five
and I found ten and this girl just goes
I think he said I found 125 or something
ridiculous I mean what he's like yeah
yeah and this was like no they're not
deals they're just right moves link
she's like nope ROI I call the numbers
do I see them and it's like what have
you been doing this for a month prior
did you know this exercise was coming
nope no he literally just went on the
website and just and just pulled out all
the property so yeah and he basically
got him on the mic and I remember
because I actually haven't even told
this to Russell this is very news to you
as well the guy text me at the time this
happened I opened up Google Analytics
and all of a sudden the traffic just
starts spiking yeah and it was because
he spoke on the mic invented it I was
like I use the heel sauce okay this is
gonna work really I need to talk to yeah
yeah yeah that's great that's great
because again if someone's used it I did
value stories sell write facts tell yeah
exactly yeah that's that that's so good
and I think that's that's kind of what
caught my attention when I saw people
using it I was I didn't even I don't
really even look to it because I'm so
untuk II but then when you came in and I
thought alright come on let's talk and
then I looked at it suddenly it went
from you trying to get my attention to
me being like okay I want I want to buy
to this I want I want in on yeah I
remember leaving that meeting and me and
undress or talking we're like we should
have done that we said that and then I
got the message that evening from from
you and it was like you should be so
proud this app is great I can't remember
what you said it was yeah and I was like
okay okay yeah yeah right
great so yeah and the rest is history so
that's awesome yeah so right now then so
and it's an app but it's also a website
so you don't if you're not techie that
was one of the things that put me off
from like an app oh no an app I'm just
so not that way inclined but then
website let's have a look oh my goodness
it's an app and it's a website and it
just does everything that's gonna save
me time so no it's really really good
I'm super impressed with it I'm really
honored and proud to be part of the deal
saucer app as well I know we've got more
crazy things lined up as well in the
pipeline to do you know projects and
stuff to do together but this is clearly
working people I clearly loving it what
would be your biggest advice to someone
that's wanting to just become successful
whether that be in property in business
like from your from your experience of
creating the app succeeding in property
of going through the Academy I won't be
the top biggest takeaways that you give
to people I guess you've got to have
you've got to have a big reason why what
you're doing what you want to do because
you need that when it's difficult so you
need you need a big why and then you've
got to go out there and work really
really hard but just focus on adding
value that's that's the only thing that
matters that kind of leads everything
that makes everything easier yeah you
know just go work hard and I would I
would do the courses I mean for goodness
sake like your stuff is all now
available online for like so much
cheaper than a pound yeah I just do that
go sell a bunch of deals
it depends what you're doing but I guess
if it's anything else you just got to
put in the work and you've got to have a
you've got to have a why and yeah that's
that's it I'm already good well like
that work hard like that don't I think
like people need to really realize what
it takes to be successful these days I
think we've been like mollycoddled a
little bit
yeah you've really got put in the work
so what was your why when you join the
Academy my family and me I always wanted
to make them financially free and myself
and that's it I don't want to give the
long story but you know my sister went
through quite a bad experience but five
years ago she suffered a brain injury
and and that kind of just poured more
gasoline on the fire I always wanted to
make them you know free I grew up like
you cancellous eight you know all that
kind of normal stuff really okay you
don't you don't come across like that no
no that's that's where I'm from
that's where I'm really from that's
where I'm born and bred yeah where did
you go up place called Ipswich yes I
grew up in a council estate called
Chantry and yeah I I got to see like
when I was younger you know my mum and
dad you know in the end they did well
but like I saw them go through the early
90s where the interest rates went up
they lost their house it and I got to
see like I'm from that point on I was
like I don't want I want them to be free
financially but also I don't want to
have to go through that mmm you saw what
poverty looks like or at least you saw
what's real financial struggle looks
like yeah yeah I got to see struggle you
know you know and you're a kid and
things don't you know but you realize
later on what they are what those
moments were and yeah I I didn't want
that for them and has always driven me
and yeah I just like you you know like
you can go out and get whatever you want
you've got put in the work so but man
stuff is what defines you I think why
did you sister you said channa brain
injury he said why how did that
correlate do you want him to be
successful in business and so I was
already at the time I'd started a tech
business I'd ventured out into being an
entrepreneur we raised a bunch of money
who raised about a million quid started
this new tech startup and I was in the
middle of growing that and she after
having a son she suffered a there was
negligence at the hospital basically so
she got a brain injury
from it and she's with us today and
we're very lucky and
yeah just that just poured gasoline on
the fire I was already ambitious but
that was always in my mind when I was at
that previous startup because I was I
wasn't helping them enough I was
constantly working on this startup that
was you know most startups they require
a lot of investment in time and I was
like I need to go and I need to help
them I need to do more and yeah it just
just made it more real
I remember at DFA I spoke about it and
you got me on stage and asked me to talk
about my why and I was talking about
then I think everyone everyone has this
on some level they have a why and you've
got really focus on that in the
difficult times and that's exactly what
I'm about finding people that like you
grew up in accounts of the state got a
strong why and then and then channeling
those people to be the best their most
successful that I can possibly be you
know for me that's people ask me why I
do what I do you know why I teach and
why run a training company and it's it's
exactly for this reason and also
potential joint ventures like if I
didn't have a training company we
wouldn't have met and now I wouldn't
have the app no it's it's a real godsend
cuz I was in when I was in the last
startup it was it was hard it was really
hard and I remember watching your videos
and they would boost me up and then
after I joined I was like yeah I'm out
I'm out of here and I'm gonna I'm gonna
work on property and this took off so
without the Academy there would be no
deals or so there would be non unless
it's excited what's next then what are
you gonna be doing while you're in Italy
and traveling all over the world scaling
this business with you yeah yeah I'm
scaling this business also artificial
intelligence I'm spending a lot of time
working on artificial intelligence
that's the kind of next wave that we're
gonna see in the world so I'd love to do
some stuff in cancer detection and
things like that yeah so so yeah
building building products that you know
improve humanity and you know yes in
society really possible technology of
really is possible yeah you're an
interesting guy and I think that for
anyone watching this who's in property
or even if you're not and you want to
get in property not only would I urge
you to go and get the
or to get go on the website register its
peanuts it's like 45 Panama and there's
a discount so it's less than I don't
know what the figure is 35 35 pound a
month but also share the word like tell
people about this web about this website
about this app and support Ashley in
this as well I know that we're business
departments in the app but I just think
it's gonna this potentially is just
going to completely it is going to
revolutionize the way that people do
property it's gonna it's it's it's a
much the barrier to entry and properties
become lower because rather than people
thinking I'm really confused I don't
know where to start I don't know how to
work out the return on investment I
don't know how to find it's just it's
there so I'm really excited I'm really
really really impressed and proud of
what you've done and just honored to be
part of it so - so thanks for coming on
when it's on a Wednesday and I look
forward to continuing communicating over
zoom calls while you're all over the
world thank you thank you so much guys I
hope you enjoyed the interview of course
in the description you can check on the
website check on the apps and start
seeing these types of deals also don't
forget to drop a comment below give some
support to Ashley also smash the like
button and if you're not already
subscribe subscribe turn the
notification about on and I'll see you
next time
[Music]
yeah you must be blinded by the lies